bonjour à tous aujourd'hui nous vous
présentons un arbre remarquable
châtaignier non-vie philippe va nous
parler
bonjour bienvenue dans la forêt de cloud
bas dans la vallée de munster plaisante
et de châtaigniers remarquable de quatre
trous 4 du fait de ses quatre sections
entières et qui en font le plus gros
châtaignes et d'alsace donc je vais vous
parler un petit peu de cet arbre d'abord
de ses dimensions
c'est un châtaignier qui fait 8 mètre
soixante de circonférence
pour un peu plus de trois mètres de
diamètre est plus une haute estime et de
34 à estimer parce que du fait qu on est
dans un massif ouest est assez dense et
qui a pas mal de pente
c'est difficile de prendre ses repères
pour alors l'arbre à quelques
caractéristiques particulières il a un
tronc unique très beau et sur le versant
avant est à peu près un mec et sur le
versant aval qui fait à peu près 3 m au
bar de gares et de charpente hier jeudi
et non pas ce que chacune des branches
représente la taille d'un chat d'un
châtaignier remarquable normale entre
guillemets parce et arbres se trouve
dans une forêt communale gérée par le nf
et qui nous a été signalé par personne
des personnes âgées du village de
brisbane dans le cadre de l'inventaire
que nous faisons dans le haut var
ya pas mal de particuliers qui nous
signale des arbres remarquables voir
qu'on a mesurée quand on compare à nos
bases de données et c'est comme ça il ya
quelques années que ce que cette
personne nous a signalé qu' à l'époque
de son enfance se trouvait dans une
prairie dans un pâturage d'altitude est
donc cet arbre est resté un peu dans
l'anonymat à ce que la forêt s'est
refermé sur lui hélas la plus ou moins
cachés dans sauf que la personne en
question avait gardé le souvenir de
souvenirs d'enfance d'elle de son père
qui se cachaient dans leurs trompettes
d'y jouer
donc c'est à moi nous l'avons mesurée
nous l'avons signalé
il a été inséré dans le livre des arbres
remarquables et il a fait l'objet de
nombreux articles dans la presse donc au
point de vue de son âge je ne vous ai
pas parlé de son âge l'âge des arbres
est très difficile à définir
parce que les facteurs de l'apport en
eau les facteurs d'ensoleillement les
facteurs de qualité du sol font
énormément varier la vitesse de
croissance de la nés en moins d'après
138 70
c'est un acte qui ne peut pas avoir
moins de 200 ans il va avoir au moins
deux cents ans peut-être sans en plus on
ne sait pas il faudrait pour cela faire
un carottage dans le tronc donc avantage
que souhaitons pas faire tout simplement
parce que de faire enfler des bactéries
à laquelle on pense comprendra l'une
pour le moment six nations et aussillon
est simplement se laisser gagner par la
magie des sujets
c'est un art on dirait inexplicablement
a survécu que les châtaigniers chacun c
était très très recherché il ya quelques
décennies pour ses qualités hydrofuge
notamment par les vignerons
l'epic est finie a été fait dans le
temps presque exclusivement en bois de
châtaignier et en bois d'acacia et donc
de ce fait dès qu'ils atteignaient un
certain diamètre il était
systématiquement groupe et est exploité
pour faire des piquets natura jouent des
pick est donc celui là a survécu
peut-être que c'est sa forme
particulière qui a fait que l' arrivée
jusqu'à ce jour là toujours est il qu
aujourd'hui vu sa taille c'est un arbre
il est en état sanitaire plus tôt
bernard qui a une espérance de vie très
sain donc il faut rappeler que les
châtaigniers dans d'autres régions
notamment en bretagne peuvent atteindre
des âges de huit cents à milan donc
celui ci est dans sa jeunesse 6 ans à
venir
pas en terme de taille parce que live a
pu boire énormément de l'ensoleillement
et l'exposition
en revanche il va vieillir certainement
pendant un bon moment
si l'homme
donc voilà c'est peut-être la
présentation du plus proche a gagné
d'alsace et on se retrouvera peut-être
une autre occasion pour présenter
d'autres arbres du même acabit mais dans
d'autres masses